LAURA LING: Dr. Tiffany
Anderson, superintendent
of the Jennings School
District, begins her morning
with a four-hour
commute to work,
after which she can be
found, sneakers and all, out
on crossing guard duty.
Anderson oversees seven schools,
3,000 students, and hundreds
of teachers and staff.
But there's no job she won't do.
TIFFANY ANDERSON: I bring
hot chocolate, coats.
I'm the first face
they see before they
walk through the door.
LAURA LING: Jennings is a
town of 15,000 people just
outside St. Louis, Missouri.
It borders Ferguson, which
was the center of protests
following the shooting of
an unarmed black teenager
by a white police
officer in 2014.
Like Ferguson, Jennings
has a population
of mostly African
Americans, 1/4 of whom
live below the poverty line.
LAURA LING: What was the school
district like when you first
arrived?
TIFFANY ANDERSON: Four years
ago, Jennings didn't really
feel like a community
that had hope.
Almost every month,
I am attending
a funeral of either a current
student or a student's parent.
And often those are
victims of crime.
We have two students at one
of our elementary schools
where they literally had
to crawl out of the window
as their mother
was being stabbed.
Things that we can't imagine.
LAURA LING:
17-year-old Gabby Scott
is a junior at
Jennings High School.
How old were you when you
found out you were pregnant?
GABBY SCOTT: 15.
That was rough.
LAURA LING: Did you cry?
GABBY SCOTT: I did.
A lot.
So much I probably don't
even have tears left.
LAURA LING: Just a few years
ago, many students in Jennings
were in danger of
not graduating.
Dropping out was not
an unusual occurrence.
Did you think about how
am I going to go to school
and have this baby?
GABBY SCOTT: That
was the first thing
that was brought to my mind.
I don't think I'm going
to be able to go to school
and be pregnant.
LAURA LING: Do you think that
people had written this school
district off?
TIFFANY ANDERSON: I
think in many ways.
Because Jennings
has so much poverty,
people really weren't sure
if improvement was possible.
LAURA LING: With
grants, partnerships,
and some creativity, Dr.
Anderson balanced the budget,
launched a college prep
program, and brought back
arts education.
She also began to
address issues that
stemmed far beyond academics.
TIFFANY ANDERSON: I learned that
food was the greatest issue,
so we decided we would
open a food pantry.
We give out 8,000
pounds of food a month.
Approximately 200 to 400
people every two weeks
get food from Jennings.
And then we looked
at health care.
We have about two to three
mental health therapists
at every school.
Washington University,
they agreed to partner,
and they provide a pediatrician.
So look, you break an
arm, just come to school.
We got it.
LAURA LING: This is a place
where parents can come and do
their laundry for
free in exchange
for volunteering an hour
of their time at school.
And it's pretty incredible,
when you think about it,
because it's such a simple
way to get parents involved,
while at the same time
addressing the very real needs
of many if these families.
TIFFANY ANDERSON: We generally
say, if all you can do
is make it to school, we'll
take care of the rest.
Food, clothes,
shoes, health care.
LAURA LING: What
kind of changes did
you start to see
in your students
when you started to
remove those barriers?
TIFFANY ANDERSON: So when
kids knew that we cared,
there was almost like
this light bulb went off.
This willingness to try.
And we are now fully accredited.
Four years ago we were
meeting 57% of the standards.
We're now meeting 81%.
We've been exceeding
the state benchmarks
for two consecutive years.
LAURA LING: Dr. Anderson
also introduced a program
to support teen moms
like Gabby, as well
as parents in the community.
It allowed Gabby to
stay focused on school
while raising her son Carter.
On top of having a baby, you
are a straight-A student, right?
GABBY SCOTT: Yes.
LAURA LING: And you are
going to be class president.
GABBY SCOTT: Yes.
And you're on your way
to being valedictorian.
GABBY SCOTT: Yes.
LAURA LING: How are you doing
this all and managing it all?
GABBY SCOTT: I have teachers
who are willing to work
with me and my time management.
Carter comes with me to
my student council events.
LAURA LING: If you were pregnant
before all of these programs
were introduced,
before Dr. Anderson,
what do you think your
life would be like?
GABBY SCOTT: Probably would
have given up a long time ago.
But with the support of
Jennings and their programs,
it's been easier.
We are all passing our tests,
willing to come to school.
It's making us more
excited to be here.
LAURA LING: This community
borders Ferguson,
which has seen a lot of unrest.
This is a critical
time in our country.
Has that brought greater urgency
to the work that you do here?
TIFFANY ANDERSON:
I believe our role
is to show people that there
is a system of oppression,
and to gain the greatest
amount of education they can
so that they have the
power to make changes.
LAURA LING: Can this work be
replicated in many places?
TIFFANY ANDERSON: This
work we've done in Jennings
can happen anywhere, in any size
district, and in any community.
Zip codes should not
determine the quality
of education or health care.
And we will not allow for that
to determine where kids end up.
LAURA LING: To see how
this young woman conquered
incredible odds to become
a Gates Millennial Scholar,
watch this next video.
SUBJECT: Outside of my
house, it was a lot of gangs.
And my sister was always
involved with them.
I saw so many graphic things
that she went through.
LAURA LING: Did you ever
think about joining a gang?
SUBJECT: No.
It made me more focused.
I was always the
nerd of the family.
LAURA LING: Please don't
forget to subscribe
to "Secret Stories."
You can see new
videos every week.